There's a lot of cool trivia out there about
Darth Vader, the most legendary villain in
the Star Wars universe.
Did you know it took five separate actors
to bring Luke's father to life in the original
flicks?
Or that James Earl Jones wasn't credited as
the voice of Vader until Return of the Jedi?
That kind of knowledge might help you win
a pub quiz, but it's just scratching the surface.
Let's talk about some deep cuts.
Here are some facts about the Sith lord only
true Vader nerds know...
Darth Ubiquitous
Vader is the only human character to appear
in every main Star Wars feature film in some
way, shape, or form.
Not Han, not Leia, not Luke ... not Porkins,
unfortunately É
É only the half-human, cyborg Darth Vader
can claim that title.
"You are beaten!
It is useless to resist."
Obviously, Vader's villainy was central to
the original trilogy, and his origin story
formed the entire backbone of prequels.
But thirty years after Darth Vader's death
within the Star Wars universe, he remains
so important that he even showed up in episode
seven É or at least his mangled helmet did
É and he also made a stunning appearance
in 2016's Rogue One, which brings us to ...
Darth Expeditious
Although the Sith Lord's appearance onscreen
midway through Rogue One was written into
the script from the get-go, his most incredible
scene came at the very end, and foreshadowed
Vader's reign of terror in the original trilogy
to come: an intense hallway battle sequence
in which a besieged ship full of rebels raced
to escape with their stolen blueprints for
the Death Star.
All while Vader advanced on them, lightsaber
in hand, cutting down every last man with
casual brutality.
It's an incredible moment, made that much
more remarkable because it was tacked on at
the last possible moment after Rogue One's
editor argued Vader needed more screentime.
Director Gareth Edwards said editor Jabez
Olssen thought one more badass moment was
called for.
But Olssen's timing was awful: the film was
about four months from release.
Ultimately, the sequence was shot in three
days Ñ an incredible feat, considering it
ended up being among the best and most memorable
scenes in the entire film.
Darth Repetitious
Vader was downright terrifying in Rogue One,
but if you look closely at his deadly stroll
down that hallway, you'll realize you've seen
all of these moves before.
They didn't teach an old dog new tricks É
"Ah!
Thy will be done, Lord Vader."
He deflects laser blasts É uses the force
to lift and choke É as well as disarm É and
there's of course the lightsaber hacking and
slashing we all know and love.
While it may have been tempting to give the
old-school Vader a new trick or two, according
to director Gareth Edwards, keeping his deadly
skill set familiar was "the golden rule" ...
"Everything you sort of see him doing down
that corridor is pretty much something from
the previous films."
É which is why Vader wasn't breakdance fighting
or shooting fireballs from his hands.
Good call.
Darth Minimus
Forget that handless farmboy Luke Skywalker:
Vader's the real star of the series, having
left his mark on every episode and then some.
But did you know that the franchise's fallen
hero, the most iconic villain in all of sci-fi,
was in the first movie for fewer than ten
minutes.
Ten minutes!
That's like half a Fresh Prince episode, without
the commercials É
"Ochina one little fight in a waslano scared
and witninnie witnnoone auntie and uncle in
Bel-Air."
It feels like he's in the film for much longer,
which is a testament to how effective those
ten minutes were in introducing such an enigmatic
and menacing character.
Compare that to the insufferable seventeen
minutes plus we had to spend with Jar Jar
Binks in Episode One .. it's enough to make
you want to Force Choke yourself to death...
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!